i realized that i was carrying so much
of what wasn't mine and like through
doing therapy like i realized like okay
that's not mine that's not mine cake
this is mine i just kind of like try to
sit with myself if i'm like feeling an
overwhelming amount of emotion and try
to understand like okay whose is this
like is this mine is this knee tending
to or should i put this should i give
this back to like its rightful owner
because i i do carry a lot of stuff um
and i guess that just comes with like
feeling guilty a lot like i hold a lot
of guilt for things feeling guilty about
having these negative emotions and
feeling depressed and anxious when my
life on paper is so wonderful you know
there's a lot of shame that came with
that and like shame i always say is like
such a pointless emotion and guilt is
such a pointless emotion because you
can't do anything with it it just kind
of sits there and festers there's no
real
use for it you know even anger and
sadness there's like some use for that
but guilt and shame is just a really
bad emotion that you gotta you know get
out of your system
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today we have alessia cara she is
canadian but she didn't know that she
was 2018 grammy winner for best new
artist she has her third album coming
out which is called in the meantime and
she's releasing two songs at once to
start off with in honor of the album
being rooted in duality so those two
songs kind of represent that uh the
songs are sweet dream and shapeshifter
man she is a um
a really insightful deep thoughtful girl
she's in her mid-20s talking about
concepts and realizing concepts that
i've taken into my later 30s to realize
so you know there was a lot of talk
about what sourced this album and the
things that she went through
last year that led her to where she's at
and i think that you know at the end of
the interview you'll hear more about it
but just her vulnerability is really
endearing and i think that's why her
music resonates with so many and she
writes it all herself too i mean it's
crazy i think there's stories about like
bathtub writing but
uh on this album there was definitely
some big songs that came from some of
her sleepless nights and some of the
discomfort she had in the insomnia and
all of the other things the anxiety the
stuff that so many of us probably
experienced in the last year but she
turned it into art just a really
beautiful soul
very vulnerable very honest and a damn
good singer so enjoy the interview how
does it feel once you get to that point
is it almost like
so exciting to talk about it or is it
like damn this is the part that i'm like
oh i gotta get through like the
writing's fun album's fun recording's
fun but then you know hours of
interviews for i don't know i mean i'm
sure you have more than one day's worth
yeah definitely definitely more than one
i mean it's in between i think for me
like i'm excited when it comes to
talking about um like the full album
especially this one because i don't know
it's just like my favorite thing i've
ever made and i'm excited to to talk
about it i think you know talking about
the music is is my favorite part and
like having conversations i guess like
answering some of the more generic
questions can be a little mundane and
redundant but um
but i don't know like i i've been
enjoying like talking about this new
music especially because you know after
the year we've all had it was
you know it's kind of nice to just be
back doing you know business as usual
yeah
yeah i'm i'm sure i mean i even feel
like
i went to a concert the other night i
interviewed a girl named lisa uh lindsey
stirling she's a violinist and she puts
on these really cool shows and so i went
and watched her the other night and i'm
like it's so fun to be out and see
people and then you see all these
pictures of concerts happening and i
feel like or even sporting events you
know football games starting and stuff
like that and you just see it full and
i'm like people are so eager to get back
out there and do things with each other
and be outside and or be in a big public
space
and so i think that um i think there's
going to be a lot of hunger for probably
not only just you know something new but
then also whenever it comes time to tour
do you guys plan the tour quickly or is
it is that not how it happens like album
and then wait
um well usually
um you know over the last seven years
we've kind of like planned the tour way
way in advance like that's typically how
tours get planned but i think this year
again just coming out of like the chaos
that happened it's it's a little bit
different this time we haven't planned
anything yet i think it's like now
everybody's trying to like book venues
and stuff because you know everyone was
kind of delayed so it's harder to like
get slots and get dates so it's a little
bit more challenging to book
tours this year um i haven't started
thinking about it yet well i've started
thinking about it but i haven't actually
started like booking anything yet so
hopefully soon cause um yeah it would be
nice to to get out there again okay so
you said you don't want any of the
mundane questions and look i get it like
i was a race car driver for a long time
and i also
hate surface level conversations i find
them to be really exhausting
so i'm not going to do any of that to
you other than
ignorance from my part on the music
industry and yourself but
let me let me go in and i'm gonna like
this is gonna be kind of a big question
but hopefully
you'll see where i'm going with this
quickly with the question after it so
um
the question is what do you think the
purpose of
this human existence is
man
that is an excellent question i think
that is something that i grapple with
truly every
day i think that's been like the biggest
challenge for me is finding meaning in
all of this
um but i guess i guess the purpose
to me um or like what i've decided it is
is like you know we have
moments in life um big and small and
it's just about applying
meaning to it whatever that is to you i
think um
because i mean sometimes i think like is
there any meaning at all like maybe
we're just here to be here and that's it
but i guess it's like it's about what
meaning you apply to it you know and
maybe what you can leave behind and
finding some sort of permanence in the
impermanence um
because you know the idea of of uh
impermanence is very scary to me it's
something that i've always been so like
fearful of the idea of like fleeting
life and
um the fact that everything you do here
can just like be gone you know so i
guess it's just about applying meaning
to it wow
okay
well i'm gonna cut to the chase so that
you understand why i asked such a
sort of big question but i also think
something that you said right there was
very interesting too um that i want to
ask a question about but the purpose is
because whenever i've been asked that
question or whenever i've asked myself
that question
the answer i come up with or i have come
up with years ago was that i think that
the purpose of this existence is to
experience duality
and
i know that that's the theme of your
album so i was very curious to hear what
you thought and then for you to just
talk about what duality then i guess
what does duality mean to you that's a
theme
why is why why did that come up
for you
yeah well i think it was for a few
different reasons or in a few different
ways i think first off um there's kind
of a through line or a thread on this
project where it feels sort of like a
point a and a point b like the beginning
of the album is you know my mindset in
the place that i was in you know in the
first half of the year and then as the
the songs you know go on and as you know
the story progresses um there's like a
point b is sort of where i ended up and
where i kind of am now
um you know on the second half of that
year in the second half of the the
writing process but also again like this
year was er in last year was like super
challenging for me in many ways i was
faced with like um
i guess like death for the first time
somebody really close to me got very ill
and i think that's when i started
thinking a lot about the meaning of
existence and life and death and i
you know just like realized that like
nothing and everything matters at the
exact same time and you know and that's
kind of like where the whole idea of
duality came in and i realized how
important it kind of is and how
prominent it is in life you know like we
are made up of duality and like
it's like it's kind of like i don't know
like there's like two sides to one coin
in life you know and like nothing
matters but at the same time everything
matters in a way and i still don't even
like quite understand what that exactly
means or how to navigate that but that's
just kind of the conclusion i've come to
and um yeah just duality has been
extremely present in my in my life but
also in my writing process and like
looking at pain from two different ways
and just looking at life in general from
two different ways whenever i experience
something and for some reason it usually
has to be negative but when i
experienced something really hard and
difficult and negative and my last year
was a total evolution and and growth
period for for me as well and so i'm
curious and we've talked about it being
like coming this album comes on the
heels of so much growth and so much a
hard time um but when i experience the
negative it gives me pers it gives me
the positive
equal and opposite like i can i
experience so much pain and sadness but
i was able to then experience this very
simple blissful joy
in a really like basic moment of looking
at a tree
so
it's like such a bummer
but it's like to get the pleasure you
have to experience the pain but i feel
like
duality for me kind of expanded and once
it once one expanded i realized that
there was an equal and opposite sort of
reaction on the other side and what i
ended up realizing
through that experience of enough times
of that negative through different
things whether it be the ways ways that
i felt something that i was thinking
all kinds of stuff is that i was like
holy [ __ ] i'm like it's part of the same
hole
which then leads to oneness
and i was like wow they feel like you
know duality to me felt like bad and
good you know but what i realized is
that it's all part of the same whole
100
yeah it's like one can't necessarily
exist without the other you can't really
like
look at one thing the same way without
the other i know for me like i hit some
of the you know the heaviest rock
bottoms in the last couple years and
like you know when you're so not okay
like
you hold on to the moments where you are
okay so much more even if they're like
like you said like little mundane simple
basic moments that you wouldn't have you
know looked twice at before
suddenly are just so much more
important to you you know when you when
you experience the other end of that
duality of like you know just feeling so
not okay and not seeing any light at all
that when you do find any glimmer of
light again it's like applying more
meaning to it like the same things can
happen to us but at different times in
our lives they mean such different
things just because of perspective you
know you just realize how much
it life really is about perspective
it's all perspective essentially i i
mean i think i think you've nailed it
it's
it's what meaning we attach to something
it's how we decide to see it it's like i
remember when i was having my saddest of
times i like love going out and walking
in the woods in nature and
have my dogs with me and my mom and you
know and she would be out walking and
she'd be like man it's such a beautiful
day and i didn't notice it at all like i
couldn't even notice how beautiful the
day was
at all um so what were the
if you're willing to share what were the
things that kind of put you in that
put that put you in that space was it
professional was it personal was it
lost like what what got you there
um it was i think a collection of
different things i think you know a big
chunk of it was um
just suppressing a lot of
feelings um that i you know thought i
had gotten over but i was actually just
pushing down over the last seven years
in my career i think this very
fast-paced lifestyle doesn't really
allow you to process emotions or process
things in a normal
way um
and so i just thought like oh wow like
you know i can just get over things and
i'm strong and whatever but what i
thought was actually being strong or
what i thought was healing was actually
just complete suppression and throwing
under the rug
and it wasn't until i had like you know
a complete halt in life until we all
experienced that halt and that like
complete lack of distraction where i
like
everything just sort of boiled over but
then also you know experiencing somebody
really close to me being so close to
death and
um i mean i've always had like a weird
phobia of death but it wasn't until
that i was like faced with that and like
was so close to it for the first time
that i really went into this spiral of
like okay what is the meaning of life i
mean i attach so much
meaning so much of my identity to my job
and what i do for a living you know and
again so when i didn't have that when i
didn't have that distraction i was just
like well okay who am i what's the point
of anything
you know how can all these good people
just go
you know and then what happens to us
after like i was just in a complete
spiral of thought and fear and my phobia
turned into like full-blown panic attack
and
panic disorder and um
you know i just i was just like
completely
just off the rails it felt like yeah
yeah i just completely spiraled um so
yeah it was like it was a collection of
different things a lot of suppressing a
lot of like
going down rabbit holes of thought with
no answer because obviously like you
know there is no real answer to what is
the meaning of life and what happens
after we die so it's not just fun to
talk about
yeah so there's no way that i could like
talk myself down in a logical way and so
i i lost like the color to life because
i was like well nothing matters and like
you were saying sorry to go on a tangent
but i love it
that's what i'm asking for
cool um well yeah you touch on a good
point where like you know you would go
on walks and your mom would be like oh
like what a beautiful day i remember
like people would say that all the time
and like in a cerebral
logical rational way i knew like the
right answer would be like yeah it is
right that's the thing you say like yeah
i guess it's a nice day but i wouldn't
actually really feel it or see it i
would just like respond because that's
what you do you say yeah it is or
whatever you know right and it wasn't
until like i really really like did the
proper healing and like went to like
therapy and just really like hashed a
lot of things out with myself that i was
able to actually like enjoy and for the
first time the last few months i've been
able to like walk outside and like think
to myself like it is a nice day like
this is what people were seeing like the
blinders are kind of off
um and it's not like a black and white
thing of course it's not like suddenly
the veil has been lifted and life is
amazing but you know it's definitely a
cyclical thing and i have days where you
know that feel a little bit grayer still
but i'm able to have those moments now
where i understand like what people are
talking about about it being a nice day
or like enjoying and appreciating
moments you know oh my god i'm sure that
is exciting because in a way you're like
oh my god i've made progress because
sometimes it's freaking hard like when
it's you you feel you know you're you
every day and it's hard to notice
changes when you're standing in the
middle of it you know you're in the
forest but then when you get those
breakthroughs where you all of a sudden
are like oh that's so nice wow i get it
so i a theme that that that comes up
again and again that i'm really curious
about is this theme of loss
and
i'm
curious where
that pain comes from you said you did
therapy so i'm curious if like your
therapist has kind of
dug into that and tried to figure out
kind of what it is about loss that's
scary is it a is it an anxious
attachment wound was there like
inconsistent uh
you know parenting along the way because
you know i i have that where i was have
you heard about um attachment styles
yes
so i mean i was totally anxious
attachment where i was afraid of being
abandoned and it really was rooted in
the fact that
it wasn't my parents were wonderful
they're still married but my mom stayed
home with me and my dad
would go to work and i barely saw him i
don't think i saw him like at all during
the week and i just see him on the
weekend so what a kid learns is that i
don't know when dad's coming back i have
no rationing skills to go dad's at work
i just know that he's kind of there and
not there and so inconsistent um
uh
appearance of parents is what can cause
that abandonment wound and so that was
like one part i mean trust me there was
mom part two the process this past year
but that was the dad part so i'm
wondering if there's an abandonment
wound somehow or or what could have what
drives this this fear of of loss
yeah definitely um i am the exact same
way like i feel like i saw and like
heard so much of myself and like
everything you just said just
um yeah the dynamic my family dynamic i
also grew up in like a very strict
italian
household so it was like you know dad is
very like there's like not a lot of
emotional um like outpouring there dad
worked a lot mom worked a lot um so yeah
there was a lot of that there's a lot of
inconsistency i mean i grew up in a very
lovely loving household my parents are
still together thankfully so you know
but and then also throughout the like
along the way just in school growing up
in different relationships that i
developed whether it was in friendships
or
in my adult life like romantic
relationships there's a lot of like
similar patterns that were being
repeated of just like something changing
somebody meaning
and um even to this day like it's very
hard for me to open up to people
romantically or in friendships just
because i you know i just have this fear
of them just like
leaving you know um especially in my job
and what i do now is very hard to be
trusting of people because i've seen it
so many times you know just like being
used by people or just
people just completely switching it's a
it's a very fleeting you know like
friendships are very fleeting in this
business especially and it's very hard
to weed out you know the the real ones
versus you know the not real ones so i
feel like it's just been kind of a
pattern in my life before and after my
career of just like it's like
abandonment thing i do i do have that it
was hard for me to admit too because
it's like it sounds so childish like oh
you didn't abandon me but it's so true
and like our inner child i'm a lot older
than you so i have that and i just said
it and i'm almost 40. i'm 39 so
i know i think it's i mean like they say
that's one of the first things you learn
in therapy if you do go to therapy is
like your inner child still lives oh
yeah it sounded like such a weird like
campy strange thing to do to like talk
to it and like you know nurture it but i
found myself being so emotional doing
that like i've had sessions where like
i've talked to myself as a kid and i
didn't know why i would get so emotional
about it but you realize like how much
there is that innocent kid in there that
just wants to be loved and nurtured and
is so scared you know
oh you're a cancer i so i took a couple
levels of astrology so something in me
said i need to look up your chart to see
what is in there and a lot of things
make sense but first off you're a cancer
which is all about the family it's all
it's the mother it's the mother sign and
so and you're a ton of pisces which is i
get it because my mercury is in pisces
which is the way my brain thinks and so
your mercury's there your ascendants
there
your venus and mars are there and which
is all super airy and flowy and like
dreamy like i bet you could sit there
and just like
days off for a while
right and just think of amazing stories
but that makes sense that you like feel
that for your inner child because like
the nature of you is so motherly so what
i mean i've done the same thing like i
remember last year
when i was getting
more connected to my inner child i would
literally hug myself i'd literally like
go like this and i'd hug myself and i
would cry and i'm like wow and so my
inner child went from this like seeing
it for the first seeing her for the
first time like in a concrete dome like
tucked away no words no nothing to like
all of a sudden she was kind of down at
the bottom of the of the tower and she
was like at the doorway and she was like
you know standing up and she was kind of
short and she didn't still sit and say
anything and then all of a sudden she
came out and now she like walks with me
and is like bubbly chatty and she always
tells me i'm like what should i be
working on she's like just play play
um but i'm wondering what that
dialogue's been like with your inner
child and if it's changed
um i was like super not in touch with it
like for a long long time again like i
just kind of
got through things by like suppressing
and suppressing and just being like oh
that's not attached to this or that's
fine like you know i just kind of always
like pushed it down so i feel like there
was no dialogue at all like i just like
pushed her down completely
um and
yeah it was just never something that
like i just always thought you know like
you grow up and life changes and that's
it and you don't realize how much
you are affected by things when you're
younger and how much that innocence is
still in you like ultimately yeah we're
grown up and we have you know new views
and you know new experiences but
ultimately like all we are is just like
children and innocent people just that
want to be loved and want companionship
and want to be understood and um so i
think that dialogue has changed
completely with not only the way i speak
to my inner child per se but just the
way i speak to myself now
um yes you know it's the same thing i
mean it's essentially the same thing 100
yeah just a part of you it's just that
innocent
part of you that's just trying to
navigate life that you know just trying
to understand and i think for me weirdly
like i i got a dog in the pandemic as a
lot of us did i you know got a cobia
puppy and it wasn't like it kind of
clicked for me when i would like
look at her even now i look at her and
i'm like look at this like little being
this poor little thing just like relies
on me for
you know like for simple things like
food water love like to be nurtured like
if i neglected this little dog like she
would not survive in the world like she
relies on me so heavily and i just
thought like i would mom
yeah yeah you know i would i would like
never do
anything to harm this little being but
then i was looking at how i treat myself
and i'm like some days like i don't eat
because i'd be so depressed like i'd be
too depressed to eat i wouldn't feed
myself i wouldn't sleep
i wouldn't like i'd talk to myself
horribly i would do everything that i
would never do to this little being that
i love so much and i'm like how do i do
it to myself then like why do i deserve
the things that
like someone else would never deserve
you know and that's when it really
clicked i'm like why am i not treating
myself with the same care with the same
level of love and patience and care and
honestly that's when it clicked like i
have to start treating myself as if i
were treating like my dog or like a baby
you know or like someone that i love
um because we always tend to get the
brunt of our
our own judgment you know and oftentimes
the way that we speak to ourselves is
never how we would speak to
to someone we love you know so that's
honestly when it clicked is when i was
started caring for someone
else you know for this little thing this
little tiny
bundle of love you know
yeah that that that absolutely makes
sense um another aspect of being a
cancer and i think i heard that you
how old are you again
i'm i turned 25 uh last month or two
months ago now i think i heard you
talking about getting a place uh of your
own
um yeah and that is such a cancer thing
to have your space and have everything
beautiful and have
you know it's the nature of cancers to
make home and so i'm wondering how that
affected you because i feel like that
was probably a really good growth um
decision for you
a hundred thousand percent yes it was so
scary at first
um just because again like sitting with
myself is not something i'm you know
necessarily good at i can you know lead
me down a couple rabbit holes so i was a
little bit wary at first of having all
this time to myself but now it's
actually been so nice to have like a
real sense of home because over the last
seven years i've had to like find home
and other things that were like not
material and not tangible just because i
would wake up in a different bed every
day like that was just my lifestyle so
it was hard for me to like attach myself
to
a home or like a sense of home
and i felt sort of lost you know over
the years but just having this place to
go back to is so wonderful i get to like
decorate it myself and do whatever i
want in it and make my own little
decisions of like i'm going to eat this
today or i'm not going to wash the
dishes or this is when like you know
like those little small dishes
i'm not going to show you what it looks
like around this right now because like
that's for me it can be as bad as i want
it to be but you've earned it that's the
thing it's like it's kind of nice to be
able to do that like i've earned this
time in the space and like making those
little decisions has been so helpful to
me because i've just struggled so much
with control also and feeling in control
of my life and feeling like i have a
sense of like
you know home
um so this was it was such a good thing
and i i've been enjoying it so much just
like having this time and space to
myself it's been really nice because
i've pretty much kind of lived with
someone like my whole life and
i was scared to death of being single
that was part of the aban abandon was i
like i had no idea what it would be like
to be alone and then once i got alone i
was like wow this is fine
this is dangerous to know i can be alone
and it'd be totally fine but i realized
how like i thought i would you know i
wasn't sure how much things i did for
someone else versus what i did for me
but i was like oh yeah i really do like
things kind of tidy i like to sort of
curate the house i like things so have
you learned stuff about yourself and
being in your own space that you're like
i didn't realize i had this pattern in
me or this preference
yeah definitely definitely the tidiness
because you know growing up in like in
my parents house i still kind of live
there part time as well and for some
reason like i'm so messy over there but
then when i'm at my house i like i guess
maybe it's because it's mine or because
like i just feel like a closeness to it
i'm like so
tidy about it too like i hate when
things are messy i get like itchy if
like something's out of place or like
you know if i have people over like the
second they leave i'm like cleaning
everything up like i don't like for it
to be untidy or dirty in any way um
which is weird because i always thought
i was just such a messy person but i
guess that's only in my childhood house
or in places that i guess aren't mine
um which i feel bad for my mom about
because i'm like she's like why can't
you just be tidy at home too but i don't
know like something about being in my
own space like i actually do like to
keep it fairly
neat which is not something i expected
in myself because i always thought i was
just a very messy person i realized i
don't actually like to be a mess which
is kind of how i've lived for a while
but now even at my parents as i try to
be more tidy because now i know what
it's like to have your own home in your
own space and like what it takes to take
care of a
space you know you've talked about your
music being like a mirror and
our whole life is mere really i mean
this is one of the things that i've come
to realize
reality is just mirroring back me
so if i see something that you know i
might be judging it's like oh wow i can
look at that and be like i can see that
there's something i'm denying in myself
the fact that it even registers on an
emotional level means that it's in me
um the way that people even just i mean
i've had to learn about myself through
the way that people talk about me just
because
i do the same like i haven't always had
the nicest dialogue with myself and so
when people would tell me things like
yeah okay yeah okay and then finally
after enough time you go wow okay i
think they're showing me me
and the kind of people that show up in
your life you go wow they are showing me
me too by being the kind of people that
they are across the board um
so i want i'm like curious if you've
thought more about that and thought
about you know your life and your
reality and what it's showing you and
maybe even things are coming up in your
mind now
or
you know specifically them with your
music which is something you've said is
that your your your music is kind of
like a mirror and what have you learned
from that
basically i'm wondering what all your
mirrors are
that's a great question
um that's an excellent question i mean
yeah well you know on the music side of
things of course like um i think you
know other people seeing themselves in
my music has in turn
shown me parts of myself and shown me
that
you know a lot of parts that i thought
were so foreign and so like you know out
of this world
not relatable are actually so so common
and everybody else i feel like you know
just having that dialogue with my
supporters and listeners has really just
shown me that i'm not alone but then you
know on a more personal side of things
you know in my interpersonal
relationships you know another thing i
learned like through getting older is
that nobody can like make you feel
something you know like when you say
like this person made me mad or you made
me do this it's like
no someone did something and in turn you
reacted a certain way that you chose
like you you chose to react a certain
way and so i always found myself like
you know over the years whether it's in
romantic relationships or just in people
relationships like i i make myself
smaller sometimes for other people and i
always thought it was like
you know the other person's doing like
this person made me feel small but it's
like no i allowed myself to feel small
actually i made myself smaller to
appease somebody else or to not make
someone else feel bad and so
you know all those relationships have
shown me parts of myself that i
like or like tendencies and patterns
that i was doing to myself that i
thought other people were doing to me um
and so i guess just getting older and
learning what i want and don't want has
just like allowed me to
i don't know just it showed me like what
i've allowed in my life and what i've
done to myself to appease people and
like this tendency i have to make sure
that everybody else is like okay before
myself
um so yeah i feel like that's been my
biggest pattern and my biggest tendency
that's kind of been a pattern in all of
my
relationships is like just like
shrinking myself
um for others and it actually had
nothing to do with the other person it
was it was my own thing i guess so
that's been like a huge mirror for me
um that i've tried really hard not to do
anymore um that i still tend to do but i
try not to
they're hard patterns they start when
we're young they say that
our subconscious programming which
operates 95 of our life our conscious
mind is five percent of our life and
that our subconscious mind is programmed
from the last trimester
before you're born
until the first like six or maybe eight
years of your life and i don't know
about you but i actually don't remember
much before i was even 10. so like i
have no idea what my subconscious
programming was when i was a kid i have
these like images like i don't remember
my childhood in video before that age
but i remember sort of snapshot pictures
of it um but that's a kind of scary
thing right to think that
there's that much vulnerability at that
age at an age where we can't really
ration it's like
i think about parents these days and
how hard it must be to not only is it
hard to be a parent but now if i'm sort
of putting it on them like by the way
your kid's subconscious programming is
done before they even barely have
rationing skills and you're like
uh
so then the question is is what do you
do after that and how do you how do you
help them navigate out of it so
maybe maybe just for you what have you
learned that helps you navigate out of
it and helps you cope and helps you to
be able to
um
you know hug your inner child pay
attention to her stop for a moment and
think about how you feel
you how you feel
and to
um you know just be able to
uh
find find the good in things have you
what are the what are some techniques i
don't know if your therapist has given
you any or you've developed some
maybe writing is a big one yeah totally
writing is is definitely a huge one for
me
um that's just it is like a huge
coping mechanism that's just kind of how
i process
things like seeing
something on on paper like in a weird
placebo-y way like it allows me to feel
like it's out of me it's out of my
system in a sense like putting it down
you know placebo placebo is 30
so no matter what like across the board
placebo effect is about 30
effective
so
it's a pretty good default yeah that's
hey not too bad so maybe i'm onto
something um yeah that's a huge one and
i think you touched on something great
too is like how much of it is mine like
what is mine and i guess i don't know if
it's a cancer thing or just the way that
i was brought up but i or i guess the
way maybe we all kind of are programmed
initially it's like to take on the
feelings of so many other people and i
think that's your blessing
yeah a lot of your pisces the cancer is
a water sign but you're pisces heir but
you my sister's a pisces and that girl
has some antennas for days like she
knows what's coming before i mean i
don't even know why i question her
anymore but um that's definitely i think
could be very much part of your pisces
but there are some people that
definitely take on people's emotions and
that's so heavy and confusing
definitely yeah well i mean a side note
both my parents are pisces and
particularly my mom has tons in her
chart and she is like psychic like
literally she is never wrong it's scary
scary um but anyway yeah so um
back to like yeah that whole thing is
like i realized that i was carrying so
much of what wasn't mine and like
through doing therapy like i realized
like okay that's not mine that's not
mine okay this is mine this is my so
like i think now like
i just kind of like try to sit with
myself if i'm like feeling an
overwhelming amount of emotion and try
to understand like okay whose is this
like is this mine is this me tending to
or should i put this should i give this
back to like its rightful owner because
i i do carry a lot of stuff um and i
guess that just comes with like feeling
guilty a lot like i hold a lot of guilt
for things i
i guess i've just been programmed over
the years to like i don't know just
carry a lot of shame and guilt and feel
bad for decisions that i've made and
stuff and
um i'm sure that'll come somewhere i
don't know i don't know that's i again
like i
because i just need to like please
people and make sure that everybody's
okay if i feel like in any way i
contributed even the smallest amount to
someone's pain or to saying no to
somebody or hurting someone in any way
like it really i spiral like at the
thought of of hurting anybody and
because of that i just carry all this
guilt and then i carry guilt and shame
for
um like a huge part of it was like
feeling guilty about having these
negative emotions and feeling depressed
and anxious when my life on paper is so
wonderful you know there's a lot of
shame
that came with that and like shame i
always say is like such a pointless
emotion and guilt is such a pointless
emotion because you can't do anything
with it it just kind of sits there and
festers there's no real
use for it you know even anger and
sadness there's like some use for that
but guilt and shame is just a really bad
emotion that you gotta you know get out
of your system um and like train
yourself out of but it's very hard to do
um so i find myself carrying it a lot of
the time brilliant reasons
really if i'm using my own experience of
what my lesson was and what i would do
too much of it
i was so afraid of being alone
and um
i i realized that the i was and i was so
afraid of not being chosen
and my lesson was i was supposed to be
choosing myself
yeah so if i use that in this scenario
like the way that you
are doing that for other people the care
that you have for other people
is what you're supposed to be doing for
yourself 100
yeah yeah and these people are all just
showing you that they're just they're
just showing you they're your mirror to
show you like you're carrying so much
you're carrying you're here they're just
showing you this pattern over and over
and over again and really it's like for
you to do for yourself and so your inner
child right now is like jumping through
damn hula hoops right now and it's like
yeah yeah yeah hi that's me yeah 100
yeah going back to the same thing that i
was saying it's like i always thought
like
you know
people
make me do like feel certain ways
they're like you know nobody like gives
me the same love that i give them like
i'm always giving so much to people and
they're always so selfish and they don't
you know give me the same love back or
the same courtesy back and it's like
instead of thinking of it that way just
think of well why am i giving so much to
them and not enough to myself like what
these people are doing is giving
themselves the love that i should be
giving myself you know it's not like
they should be giving me more love i
should be giving myself more love so
it's the same thing that's another huge
mirror for me it's like nobody makes you
feel certain ways or like sometimes it's
not other people's fault it's just you
need to readjust the way that you are
living and what you're giving to
yourself versus what you're giving to
others and like how much of that
you want to give to either side you know
um
so yeah it ultimately was like my my
choice and it's not a bad thing to to
you know sometimes like especially as
women i feel like we put such a negative
connotation on being selfish or on you
know giving love to yourself and and
feeling confident in yourself i feel
like it's almost not allowed and again
there's so much guilt and shame around
doing things for yourself or or feeling
confident in yourself you know it's like
we're supposed to like downplay our
accomplishments and downplay
compliments and stuff and um it's just a
way that we've been like taught and
raised and i'm trying really consciously
nowadays to not do that and to like
accept compliments willingly and openly
without shutting them down or without
like you know turning it on its head
with like a a negative thing about
myself or blowing it off in some way or
yeah you know it's so helpful to
picture it like the way that something
happens in interaction you picture okay
would i ever let them like i'm allowing
it for myself which is the [ __ ] we
do to ourselves but i would never allow
this for my inner child the same thing
comes in the other direction with the
compliments it's like try and imagine it
being told to your inner child you'd be
like hell yeah she's awesome or whatever
it is you know that's a good way because
it's such a good way to bridge the gap
between
your
higher self or your intuition your inner
child is to to pretend like it's
separate but but it's not and it sort of
helps to close that gap in your heart
between you and you
100
yeah totally totally i feel like that's
been so effective in
healing that and healing her and healing
me
um
yeah for sure
you um the two songs so in in honor of
the duality of the album you have
shapeshifter and um
uh dream dream
one sweet dream and
uh i love it and the videos are so cute
you look like you have so much fun with
the videos
so what i mean unpack those from uh
in in the in the deep way in the in the
psychological way what what are those
two songs about
yeah so um the first song um like on the
the double sided coin is um sweet dream
which um like i said i mentioned like
you know the thread and sort of the
point a and point b and i think this
song represents lyrically the the point
a
um that i was dealing with the first
half of last year and kind of the first
half of my life i guess
um and it's it talks a lot about my
insomnia in my you know relationship to
sleep and nighttime or lack thereof for
my whole life but more particularly in
2020 um when everything was sort of
going on and i was having you know these
crazy bouts of anxiety that turned into
full-blown panic attacks i was i was
diagnosed with anxiety disorder and
panic disorder
all types of things that you know i was
like suddenly faced with and that
suddenly had a name and i don't know it
was like a lot to grapple with and so i
guess my insomnia just got 10 times
worse and so this song i wrote over the
course of one night slash morning i
guess um where i was
so frustrated with myself and fed up
with the fact that it felt like i was
the only person in the world that was
awake which i now know
is not the case even then i knew that it
wasn't the case especially creatives i
know that we're you know awake for a lot
of the time but i was just so frustrated
um
and and like scared to be alone i
remember i had to ask like family
members or my friends to come and sleep
over because it got to the point where i
was just terrified to be by myself
that's how bad my panic attacks got it
was a really low point i just felt
really helpless and like
childish and like like why do i just
need all this assistance like i felt so
out of control
um so psychologically there's a lot
going on it's actually a very
psychological song based on like a real
thing that was happening to my mental
health and i i wrapped it in some sort
of you know fun
paper i made it you know sound very fun
and late and i juxtaposed a lot of the
the darker themes with some humorous
lyrics but it's actually about a really
serious scary time for me and a really
low point where i was like just very
lost and
out of control it felt like i
i'm so sorry um like sleep i mean just
last night
i got a bad night's sleep and i'm a
pretty damn good sleeper and
i was like i i'm training for a marathon
so i wear this watch and so i wear it at
night to see what my recharge has been
and it recharged from like 17 to 41 out
of 100 and i'm like well i guess it's a
rest day for me and so sleep and that
was me getting six hours and 45 minutes
of sleep
with no no deep sleep though and so the
deep sleep is is the restful part for
your body
and the rem apparently is the
restfulness for your mind
um
but
one of the things that i experienced
last year for the first time too and i'm
so grateful especially having this
contrast
contrasting experience experience is
that i haven't ever had anxiety
and so for me when someone talks about
anxiety it's like have you had anxiety
and they're like well you know i get
stressed it's like no no no it's like an
orgasm you know if you've had anxiety or
not because it's like it's it's and what
i experienced i i think i only had it
like three times
and it was this
inescapable
loop of
like
frantic mind paranoia thoughts that just
kept looping and i couldn't choose a
good thought you literally couldn't
choose a good thought and i was like wow
and then the body reacts and the [ __ ]
it's a really
scary thing and you don't know how long
they're gonna go on for and luckily it
was only a few times and for a short
amount and you know i'm still not sure
if they were all mine or someone else's
um because i don't usually take on
people's energy which is also a really
freaking valuable thing
um which makes it even more important
for someone like you to probably have
some time alone and some space to be
able to reorient so you know where you
start and end and then you can really
decipher when you're taking someone
else's energy on um but but anxiety is
such a such a horrible thing and has
there been anything that's helped that
um i mean tons of things i think for me
it's like a bunch of little things it's
not it hasn't just been one thing i
think i just need a whole plan of things
unfortunately i'm just always gonna need
to be somebody who has like a whole list
of things that i do to collectively
create some sort of change but i think
like the mental aspect of it and like
rationalizing it in a way has been
extremely helpful because for so long i
i always saw it as
you know my brain and my body being
against me in a sense like why is it
turning against me i felt like something
was wrong with me
um you know there's all those things
that that go through your head because
you just feel like well this isn't me
you know it almost feels like there's
like a third you that's like doing this
and you know that it's not you but you
still can't rationalize it and so i
think getting to like the history of why
it happens and realizing that it's
actually your body trying to help you in
a sense has really helped me not feel
crazy like going back to like the
biological reasons why it happens which
i feel like it's not
talked about you know
as much as i you know
um as much as you'd think it would be
talked about um you know like the
reasons that happened like the
fight-or-flight response and the fact
that panic is just
uh like a defense mechanism and a
you know like a way to protect yourself
from fear it was actually
like from danger i guess it was actually
like going back to not to get too like
you know anthro like talk too much about
anthropology for it you know like i
think the the history of why it happens
is like our body needed anxiety and
panic in that flight or flight
fight-or-flight response to protect
ourselves from danger like back in the
days when we were like cavemen like
surrounded by lions tigers and bears or
whatever we needed that fear response as
a way to survive you know as a way to
sense fear hide from the predator you
know understand
like to sep like your your mind needed
to separate itself from from your body
so that you could be like hyper aware of
your surroundings so you that you could
be safe it was a way to protect
yourself but obviously you know we've
since evolved we don't you know we no
longer no more lions no more lions
tigers more characters
yeah that you know there's cougars just
not that kind
yeah it's a different type of thing we
don't really need to protect ourselves
from those or maybe sometimes but you
know so it's a very different thing but
our bodies and our brains can't decipher
that that our brains and bodies don't
know that we've evolved and there's no
such thing as that anymore like it you
know it's almost like i like to almost
see it as like a hard drive that's not
been updated or a computer that has this
like that needs an update and you keep
like pressing like save for later you
know so
it's like it's like a hard drive that's
not updated but it still happens in like
a way to protect us but i think now our
lions tigers and bears are different
fears it's like you know comparison fear
of rejection fear of abandonment it's
different types of fears and so those
things can be triggered
by different things
um and because there's no physical
danger in front of us our like our
brains don't know that our brain still
sends a bit of fear and thinks okay we
got gotta protect ourselves from the
lion like let's completely separate
ourselves so that's what was happening
to my to my body but i wasn't realizing
it so suddenly i would just wake up one
day and feel completely disconnected i
felt like i was dreaming i felt like i
was living in a fish bowl i would look
in the mirror and feel like i wasn't
like my reflection wasn't my own my
hands weren't my own i wasn't
recognizing my friends and family it was
petrifying but i wasn't realizing that
my brain was sensing some sort of danger
and was doing this to help me
um except the danger for me were other
types of more modern day fears and
anxiety and once i started to heal those
you know my body started you know
connecting with itself again and i was
able to
stop that from happening so now when you
know when i start to feel it i start to
realize okay what's going on what
triggered this what is this like
imaginary lion or bear in my mind and
how can i like tell my body that it's
okay and i think you know you're doing
like crazy and sad that our bodies feel
it for our minds isn't it it's like it's
so helpful but it's also so frustrating
i've had these times where all of a
sudden my stomach like i can't eat
something will happen i'm physically
manifesting where i'm going to be as a
result of something coming but i don't
know what's coming yet and i'm like this
is just like it's like
being surrounded and i'm like but where
are the assassins you know
um
is there any feeling in you that this
challenge
is part of your creativity
um i think so i think now i'm able to
use it almost like a tool and sort of
harness it and
um use it for good and like i said you
know like it is my
weird placebo way of
um feeling like i can get things out of
my system when they're on paper or like
in a more audibly tangible
way so getting in front of it in that
way has been really helpful um and
feeling like i have control over it or
feeling empowered by it in a sense
um and again like
that's kind of just the the meaning that
i choose to apply to my life is like
maybe i go through these things so that
i can put them on paper and hold a
mirror up to other people like maybe
that's the point for me to be here you
know and even if that's not true i like
to tell myself that because it it's what
helps me go through life and
helps me
you know feel like it's worth it in some
way because it's very easy for me to
spiral into a very melancholic state
where i feel like nothing matters so
that's my way of feeling like okay maybe
this is the point or this is the point
that i'm choosing to give to it you know
although it sometimes just feels
completely pointless other times it's
like a conception
yeah exactly 100 perception okay so then
the last the last question i'll ask then
because i know you need to go
um but you've talked about your writing
not really having an intention and that
that you just can put it down have you
realized because you've just said a
couple things that may indicate it have
you realized a certain style pattern or
really essentially a message
with your creativity
um
i think so i think in hindsight um
i
i guess like i've always just valued
openness and honesty and
finding power and strength in
vulnerability and in
like darkness i guess
um
and just like i don't know like i guess
the message would just be yeah that like
things aren't always okay and for the
most part at least for me they're mostly
not okay there is like
power in that and there is like strength
in that openness and honesty i guess um
i think you know a lot of people
have
coined certain phrases for me or certain
titles for me i was like you know you're
like we look to you for positivity and
you write anthems of positivity and it's
like
i don't always look at it that way i
think i i write from you know a lot of
melancholic perspectives with no
solutions like a lot of my songs don't
have like a positive solution at the end
but again i think there's like strength
in that there's strength in like not
having answers sometimes and so much
comfort in just
um like commonalities
um more so than there is strength in
solutions i think just like strength in
numbers is more valuable to me than
strength in like an answer or in
problem solving um because when i was
going through my darkest times all i
wanted to do was find
someone who was going through the same
thing to like tell me i wasn't crazy i
didn't even care at that point of like
getting out of it i just wanted someone
to be with me being like you know i
understand you when you're not going
crazy you know that was more valuable to
me than like healing at that point
that's how bad it was so that's kind of
where i find my my strength like showing
people that
you know they're they're not alone and
they're not crazy and there's somebody
in their boat too you know
well it's
one of the foundations of the blue zones
of the world which is where people live
the longest is community and
i don't think and so in community you
have connection
and it isn't
possible i don't think to have
connection unless you have vulnerability
because it's only in that vulnerability
that you create that connection with
people and so
i guess thank you for you know for me
for so many people that listen to your
music and your vulnerability creates a
connection and then creates a community
so you're doing it your community's so
big don't you worry
thank you thank you so much i appreciate
that yeah you're welcome awesome
conversation oh yeah it was really good
thank you for being so open and congrats
on your new album it's amazing and the
videos are amazing and um i've been a
fan of for a long time thank you so much
i appreciate it i'm a fan of the podcast
too i love
listening to it so
it's awesome your conversation with
jordan peterson was
spectacular oh god he's brilliant right
yeah he really is yeah cool
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button